obviously if you're in the media
business you have some interest in
things being a little volatile because
that's interesting we like news you like
news yeah this is on a level that no one
kimra my can't remember in my lifetime
anything like this the volatility of the
first four weeks of a presidency being
this up and down and there being so many
different narratives going at the same
time is it a new level of crazy for
everyone in Washington and for your
colleague he seems to the president
seems to thrive on on chaos it was like
that during the campaign that obviously
worked and it's like that now he also
likes to see he seems to like to have
different competing groups of power
competing against each other and we'd
heard about that from his business
enterprise that he liked different
people competing with each other
bouncing off each other
obviously The Apprentice was like that
as well we're just I love now that we're
using the apprentice as as a way of
trying to explain explain a presidency
yeah that's fascinating to me and now
there does seem to be the same type of
dynamic going on where there are
competing power centers and and and a
lot of things that are very confusing
and I mean I think that we all can agree
that we're not used to this level of
confusion and chaos and different
messages coming from the White House
from the president we were told that
general general Flynn was fired then we
were also told no he resigned then we
were told he was fired these are all on
the record statements made by different
people in the administration it's it's
very confusing
I like news this is exhausting though
that's the thing that I think we were
talking backstage that and I think a lot
of people feel this way and I know to
say it I'm going to include it
regardless of your politics whether
someone is a Democrat or Republican
whether someone voted for four for Trump
or didn't vote for Trump
no one can wants to see four years of
this level of seismic activity every day
I don't think that's the way we none of
us can handle that these things need to
calm down relatively soon
that's that's your hope if you're
looking for me to reassure you I cannot
I hate to tell you I cannot be that
reassuring I would like to cover the
policies that his voters voted for him
to carry out whether it was having to do
with trade or draining swamp or the
border cotton just to the tax tax tax
house code you get counterterrorism but
there is so much else going on beyond
that tweets about Meryl Streep and and
this chaos now with his National
Security Advisor being fired four weeks
into his term and we found out also by
the way one of the other reasons he was
fired and this is a story we broke on my
show was because general Flynn had put
in for a security clearance for his son
Mike Flynn Jr who was very vocal and
continues to be very vocal on Twitter
espousing all sorts of totally bizarre
and insane conspiracy theories yeah and
he put in for a security clearance for
his son vice president pants came on the
show in December then vice
president-elect pence and we broke the
news and I said did you know this did
you know that somebody had put in for
her security clearance I don't think he
did and I think that was one of the
other reasons that they were very he was
alright so I think was already strike
one against Flynn and then this other
thing happened where he had misled the
vice president about his conversation
with the Russian ambassador
you